it's been ten years since jay-z put a
ring on it from making using videos to
making babies we are doing a daily Deni
deep dive and Abbey and jay-z's rider
died decade of love on this day in 2008
Beyonce and jay-z tied the knot in a
wedding that was so top secret
it wasn't until B's all-night video in
2016 we really got to look inside their
special day but let's keep it real since
then mr. and mrs. Carter have had their
fair shares of ups and downs but today a
source tells the et they are stronger
than ever quote they went through a
rough patch a couple works very hard to
get past their issues and realize they
are better together than apart and ain't
man to that of course we know that rough
patch included that 2014 elevator
incident which really was the first
crack we saw in the Carters marriage it
wasn't until 2017 jay-z really even
talked about it
telling rap radar he and Solange put
that mess behind them never
we've had one disagreement ever before
and after we've been cool you know I'm
saying it's like my sister know I would
protect her I would you know my sister
now my my sister-in-law and that my my
sister right period I'll never forget
that surveillance footage period I mean
Solange
went ham and if that's not sister e
sisterly love I don't know what is I
couldn't say the words alright still
Beyonce jay-z showed a united front on
the run setting off on their furry joint
tour in 2014 which included adorable
Home Videos of Blue Ivy and their little
fam I was at that concert shocking I
know and Beyonce and jay-z were so
stinking cute I mean you saw their love
on the HBO special and again later that
year when Jay presented his wife with
the MTV video Vanguard Award at the VMAs
[Applause]
it's crazy to think that this all went
down before lemonade even dropped in
2016 of course on that record Beyonce
seemingly wrung out their dirty laundry
poured her soul about tales of
infidelity we may never know who Becky
was but Jade did admit he cheated on
being that therapy saved their marriage
you know for us we chose the fourth
fight for our love for our family to
give our kids a different outcome no
doubt Blue Ivy and twins Rumi and Sur
have changed everything for the couple
that's worth a reported 1.25 billion
dollars and I'm sure that had something
to do with it too but as a parents of
three prepare to take the family on the
road for their tour in June we're told B
& J's a main priority is their children
going to be a family affair
clearly beyoncé and jay-z's marriage
hasn't always been pretty but you know
what neither has their style look at
that and I have receipts here's a look
at the couple's best and worst fashion
moments Oh three Bonnie and Clyde remain
hush-hush about the relationship but
they were often spotted courtside at
basketball games and even Fashion Week
Rocking what can only be described as
questionable street wear by 2004 they
went crazy in love crazy in these
outfits the couple's first red carpet
together at the 2004 VMAs was memorable
they're matching ensembles regrettable
thankfully by the 2005 Academy Awards
the two seriously cleaned up their act a
major turning point in their style
evolution this Vince
satu since then they've turned it
completely out on a red carpet
especially the annual Met Gala in New
York City and if there's one thing
Beyonce's instagram has shown us whether
it's Grammy weekend or a weekend getaway
J&B guys have come a long way this
doesn't even include how amazing they
looked on stage during that first on the
run tour so just imagine what how these
two will look when they hit the road
again in June all right that's all the
Beyonce and jay-z for today tomorrow
comeback because we were gonna be live
on daily Denny with a very special guest
you won't want to miss it we'll be live
at 12 p.m. Pacific so see you guys then
happy Anniversary mom and dad much love